absolutely everybody thank you for
coming again today I'm joined by the
chancellor of the exchequer rashid sunic
and Jenny Harris deputy chief medical
officer yesterday I said I'd the
ambition of this government to turn the
tide against coronavirus within three
months and I want to repeat that
determination today we're going to do it
with testing we're gonna do it with new
medicines and new digital technology
that will help us to see the disease as
it is transmitted and thereby by
illuminating it to stamp it out and
above all now we're going to defeat this
disease with a huge national effort to
slow the spread by reducing unnecessary
social contact and I want to thank
everybody for following the guidance we
issued on Monday to stay at home for
seven days if you think you have the
symptoms for 14 days if anyone in your
household has either of the symptoms a
new continuous cough or a high
temperature to avoid pubs bars clubs and
restaurants to work from home if at all
possible keep washing your hands and I
know it's been tough and I know it has
been inconvenient but these actions that
we're all taking together are helping to
take the strain of our NHS and bit by
bit day by day by your actions your
restraint and your sacrifice we are
putting this country in a better and
stronger position where we will be able
to save literally thousands of lives of
people of all ages people who don't
deserve to die now people whose lives
can must and will be saved and as we
take these actions together and as we
make these sacrifices we can see the
impact on the real economy already
fantastic British companies already
under huge strain big and small workers
who are finding that their jobs are
under threat or going through no fault
of their own and to all of them
we in government say we will stand by
you and I say that two companies
remember our joint objective to beat
this virus and we will do everything in
our power to help and in just a minute
Rishi is going to explain how we're
going to help workers of all kinds to
get through this crisis supporting you
directly in a way that government has
never done before in addition to the
package that we've already set out for
for business and of course these
measures are intended these steps that
we're taking are intended to be
temporary and of course I am confident
that in time the UK economy is going to
bounce back and of course it is but I
must be absolutely clear with you the
speed of our eventual recovery depends
entirely on our ability our collective
ability to get on top of the virus now
and that means we have to take the next
steps on scientific advice and following
our plan we are strengthening the
measures announced on Monday which you
remember and already people have made a
huge effort to comply with those
measures for avoiding unnecessary social
contact but we need now to push down
further on that curve of transmission
between us and so following an agreement
between all the four nations of the
United Kingdom all the devolved
administration's we are collectively
telling telling cafes pubs bars and
restaurants to close tonight as soon as
they reasonably can and not to open
tomorrow though to be clear they can
continue to provide takeout services
we're also telling nightclubs theatres
cinemas gyms and leisure centres to
close on the same time scale
now these are places where people come
together and indeed the whole purpose in
many cases of these the businesses is to
bring people together but the sad thing
is I'm afraid today for now at least
physically we need to keep people apart
and I want to stress that we will review
the situation each month to see if we
can relax any of these measures and
listening to what I have just said some
people may of course be tempted to go
out tonight and I say to you please
don't you may think that you're
invincible but there is no guarantee
that you will get mild symptoms and you
can still be a carrier of the disease
and pass it on to others so that's why
as far as possible we want you to stay
at home that's how we can protect our in
the HS and save lives I know to repeat I
know how difficult this is and how it
seems to go against the freedom-loving
instincts of the of the British people
and I also know I also know how much
right now
workers and business deserve the
financial reassurance that we are giving
but we will get through this we will get
through it together and we will beat
this virus and to ram that point home
the more effectively we follow the
advice that we are given the faster this
country will stage both a medical and an
economic recovery info thank you very
much I'm gonna pass now to to Rishi
who's going to explain some of the
explain the financial support for
workers Thank You Prime Minister good
afternoon the economic intervention that
I'm announcing today is unprecedented in
the history of the British state
combined with our previous announcements
on public services and business support
our planned economic response will
be one of the most comprehensive in the
world let me speak directly to people's
concerns I know that people are worried
about losing their jobs
about being not being able to pay the
rent or mortgage about not having enough
set by for food and bills I know that
some people in the last few days have
already lost their jobs to all those at
home right now anxious about the days
ahead I say this you will not face this
alone but getting through this will
require a collective national effort
with a role for everyone to play people
businesses government it's on all of us
to meet our commitment to that effort I
am today announcing a combination of
measures unprecedented for a government
of this nation our plan for people's
jobs and incomes will protect people's
jobs offer more generous support to
those who are without employment
strengthen the safety net for those who
work for themselves and help people stay
in their homes the first part of our
plan is to protect people's jobs this
week the government has taken
unprecedented steps to fight the
coronavirus we have closed schools we
have told people to stay at home to
prevent the spread of infection we are
now closing shops restaurants bars those
steps are necessary to save lives but we
don't do this lightly
we know these measures will have a
significant economic impact I have a
responsibility to make sure that we
protect as far as possible people's jobs
and incomes today I can announce it for
the first time in our history the
government is going to step in and help
to pay people's wages we're setting up a
new coronavirus job retention scheme any
employer in the country small or large
charitable or nonprofit
we'll be eligible for the scheme
employers will be able to contact HMRC
for a grant to cover most of the wages
of people who are not working but are
furloughed and kept on payroll
rather than being laid off government
grants will cover 80 percent of the
salary of retained workers up to a total
of 2,500 pounds a month that's just
above the median income and of course
employers can top up salaries further if
they choose to
that means workers in any part of the UK
can retain their job even if their
employer cannot afford to pay them and
be paid at least 80 percent of their
salary the coronavirus job retention
scheme will cover the cost of wages back
dated to March the 1st and will be open
initially for at least three months and
I will extend the scheme for longer if
necessary I am placing no limit on the
amount of funding available for the
scheme we will pay grants to support as
many jobs as necessary and can I put on
record my thanks to the Trades Union
Congress for CBI and other business
groups for our constructive
conversations we said we would stand
together with the British people and we
meant it we have never had a scheme in
our country like this before and we're
having to build our systems from scratch
I can assure you that HMRC are working
night and day to get the scheme up and
running and we expect the first grants
to be paid within weeks and we're aiming
to get it done before the end of April
but I know that many businesses are
hurting now I've already taken
extraordinary measures to make cash
available to businesses through loans
grants and guarantees I can announce
today that the coronavirus business
interruption loan scheme will not be
interest-free
as previously planned for six months it
will now be interest-free for 12 months
and thanks to the enormous efforts of
our critical financial sir
sector those loans will now be available
starting on Monday and I will announce
further measures next week on top of
those the governor and I have already
taken to ensure that larger and
medium-sized businesses can also access
the credit they need I'm also announcing
today further cashflow support through
the cash tax system to help businesses
pay people and keep them in work I'm
deferring the next quarter of v80
payments that means no business will pay
nav 8e from now until the end of June
and you'll have until the end of the
financial year to repay those bills that
is a direct injection of over 30 billion
pounds of cash to businesses equivalent
to one and a half percent of GDP let me
speak directly to businesses I know
it's incredibly difficult out there we
in government are doing everything we
can to support you we're paying people's
wages up to 80 percent so someone can be
furloughed rather than laid off to
protect their jobs we're deferring over
30 billion pounds of taxes until the end
of the financial year we're lending
unlimited sums of money interest-free
for 12 months
we're abolishing business rates
altogether this year if you're in
hospitality retail and leisure we're
providing cash grants of twenty five
thousand pounds for small business
properties the government is doing its
best to stand behind you and I am asking
you to do your best to stand behind our
workers we're launching in the coming
days a major national advertising
campaign to communicate the available
business support for businesses and
people please look very carefully at
that support before making any decisions
to lay people off it's on all of us we
are starting a great national effort to
protect jobs but the truth is we are
already seeing job losses
and there may be more to come I cannot
promise you that no one will face
hardship in the weeks ahead so we will
also act to protect you if the worst
happens to strengthen the safety net I'm
increasing today the Universal Credit
standard allowance for the next 12
months by 1,000 pounds a year for the
next 12 months I'm increasing the
working tax credit basic element by the
same amount as well together these
measures will benefit over 4 million of
our most vulnerable households and I'm
strengthening the safety net for
self-employed people - by suspending the
minimum income floor for everyone
affected by the economic impacts of
coronavirus that means self-employed
people can now access in full universal
credit at a rate equivalent to statutory
sick pay for employees taken together
I'm announcing nearly 7 billion pounds
of extra support through the welfare
system to strengthen the safety net and
protect people's incomes and to support
the self-employed through the tax system
I'm also announcing today that the next
self assessment payments will be
deferred to January 2021 as well as
keeping people in work and supporting
those who lose their jobs or work for
themselves our plan for jobs and incomes
will help keep a roof over your head
we've acted already to make sure
homeowners can get a three month
mortgage holiday if they need it I'm
announcing today nearly 1 billion pounds
of support for renters by increasing the
generosity of Housing Benefit and
universal credit so that the local
housing allowance will cover at least
30% of market rents in your area the
actions I have taken today represent an
unprecedented economic intervention to
support the jobs and incomes of the
British people a new comp
job retention scheme and a significantly
strengthened safety net unprecedented
measures for unprecedented times let me
close with one final observation now
more than at any time in our history we
will be judged by our capacity for
compassion our ability to come through
this won't just be down to what
government or businesses do but by the
individual acts of kindness that we show
each other the small business who does
everything they can not to lay off their
staff this student who does a shop for
their elderly neighbor the retired nurse
who volunteers to cover some shifts in
their local hospital when this is over
and it will be over we want to look back
on this moment and remember the many
small acts of kindness done by us and to
us we want to look back on this time and
remember how we thought first of others
and acted with decency we want to look
back on this time and remember how in
the face of a generation defining moment
we undertook a collective national
effort and we stood together it's on all
of us thank you